[Music]
[Music]
yeah man there's a lot to talk about and
what what a treat to be here I really
it's so good to see you my friend
Joey Lynn's brother so good to me my
Mike Tyson stories are so [ __ ] good
you know I'll go back to when my book
came out this was before we did the
Charlie Sheen roast together now I saw
Mike at the Charlie Sheen roast and I
came up to him and I said hey Mike
I you know I put out this book and I
told the story about us doing all the
cocaine in the bathroom in the book and
the lawyer said it was fine you know but
I kind of felt weird about it because I
didn't check with you and I'll never
forget Mike Mike likes me he says it
happened you tell it so great I was like
I thought man that how cool I got Mike's
blessing and then when we were on stage
I had held back the part about where we
were in the psych ward together I don't
think that that was in the book but then
because Mike said that that night or
when we actually taped the Charlie Sheen
roasts
they didn't I don't think included in
the show but I was like yeah Mike and I
were in a psych ward together and Mike
didn't give a [ __ ] about that I was I
was so psyched and I was happy to see
you could I've been there a couple of
times I haven't seen anybody know so I
went ahead and I made it part of part of
my act right I'm on in
and my stand-up and at one point I'm
doing this this interview for like GQ
calm it just seemed like them like like
this whatever interview and I'd tell the
story there and then all of a sudden
like boom its I didn't think I didn't
think anything of it
I got like I got a call weird the same
agent Chris Smith oh he's my man he
calls me up and he says hey Mike get
Mike and his camp are really unhappy
about that but the way this story went
all over the place and then later he
told me I might didn't say [ __ ] I just
didn't want you messing with his how
about that Charlie Sheen Rose I was
pretty good too dude so so we we taped
of course me I broke up broke my [ __ ]
nose at the Charlie Sheen Rose did you
madman you think that story to move set
miss foxy when we tape the Charlie Sheen
Rose this part I think is so [ __ ]
funny like whether there was like maybe
like a week before it actually aired
after we taped it and and Charlie
invited everybody that was involved with
the Rose into his house this huge
[ __ ] mansion you gotta remember his
house yeah yeah and this is like before
she got real crazy with him it was
actually it got crazy at first but
before he was crazy those everybody over
to his house before we taped the roasts
and after when it aired so it was before
we taped there was when I first met him
and we're at the house he like pulled me
aside he said party just just to hang it
wasn't like a party party in Charlie
Sheen style it was more just like
everybody meet before we work together
okay so we're at the Charlie Sheen's
house you know the first time I met in
there he pulled me aside he said you
know I'm an Stevo you and me when we go
down in flames
we don't [ __ ] around to watch it right
which was so crazy because he hadn't at
that whole like [ __ ] meltdown debacle
with the two and a half men and and he
had like I guess suppose got fired from
the show and so when the Charlie Sheen
roast aired it aired immediately after
the very first episode that featured
Ashton Kutcher Oh Ashton Kutcher
replaced him and so on on the whatever
the network the this premiere with the
Ashton Kutcher season was the the
Charlie Sheen roast on Comedy Central
aired immediately afterwards so we
watched both of them in Charlie Sheen's
living room with Charlie Sheen and he
didn't know what uh how they killed off
his character he didn't know what the
[ __ ] they did after he left so we're
sitting there in the living room with
[ __ ] Charlie Sheen while he watches
this and and it was like they they had
like his he had died and they had his
urn with the ashes and then like someone
like bumbles it and like throws the
[ __ ] thing there's the ashes go
everywhere there's a huge cloud and as
the cloud of ashes like comes down
Ashton Kutcher appears in the background
like and and Charlie watches that he
goes oh [ __ ] I gotta give it to him
that's good he didn't know dude and so
then that same night I I go and I'm like
hey dude and Charlie let's get a photo
and take a selfie me and Charlie Sheen
and after to take the selfie and then
I'm like walk around and I'm thinking
and I go over to Jeff Ross and I go dude
check it out we're in the world's I said
I think we're in the world's most
expensive crack house Charlie oh my dude
can I join I'm tweet this photo with the
caption that says
I think I'm in the world's most
expensive crack house and Charlie says
hilarious go for it I love it so I did
and then I had one of my stand-up shows
like locally in somewhere in California
that weekend so I'm on the news the next
morning and someone liked it some ladies
like she's like what can I interview you
from my thing or whatever and and she
goes he's Charlie Sheen sober and I said
I don't know I don't think so
and because I said that because I
tweeted about the crack house I got a
[ __ ] phone call from his uh his
manager this this dirty live next door
to him the dude was furious and I was
like I didn't mean to rock the boat or
UPS anyone but then I got a hold of
Charlie he said I don't care with Mike
[Laughter]
but yeah man [ __ ] that whole charlie
sheen situation is crazy I saw that he
posted that he's been sober for over a
year now which is great you know it's
great didn't but I mean I can only
imagine like the like the legal
situations that he's in now yeah you
know I mean talk about like talk about
having a lot and then he was just on top
of the world he's just got everyone's
like what the [ __ ] Charlie blew up he he
had like especially even when he left
the two-and-a-half men he turned that
into this like unprecedented anger
management contract that guaranteed like
90 episodes there's no girl yeah but but
in any case from the Charlie Sheen Rose
right this is the greatest [ __ ] story
ever this is the [ __ ] greatest story
ever and like you'd think like like
man's crazy I broke my nose on Mike
Tyson's fist at the Charlie Sheen Rose
which by the way is in my estimation the
[ __ ] coolest way you could possibly
break your nose
like Devo I don't know understand how
beautiful it was because the Charlie
Sheen Rose was 2011 right and it was I
forget like like lame longer than that
it was James 2011 now what happened was
and this is this is just so [ __ ]
incredible
the 2010 we filmed jackass 3d right and
and as part of jackass 3d my buddy Bam
Margera he's part of the show he had
this trick because we were playing
around with the super slow motion camera
for the first time the phantom camera
was brand new so we had this gag where
BAM would sneak up behind you he would
throw water through a cup of water and
your face with one hand and with this
other hand he had a boxing glove on he
would sucker punch you so as the water
hit your face the other side to slo-mo
your whole face and it was called the
rocky and they did it in slow-motion
this this super slow-motion face punch
said to the rocky theme music it's
[ __ ] hilarious if y'all see me and
now when when Bam did it to me it was it
was a real pisser because I had this
idea that I pitched I said hey dudes I
want to shoot my nipple off with a BB
gun girl right everybody said nah that's
too dark you know that's but it wasn't
yeah it wasn't as much as that it was
too dark it was just that like there's
legal implications when something is
imitatable and particularly if you're
gonna involve a gun and shooting someone
on purpose let alone in the chest that's
where the problems were but they but the
even though they knew they would never
use even though they knew they would
never use the part where I got shot in
the nipple with the BB gun they said
okay we'll let let them do it anyway
because it's a convenient a convenient
way to keep me standing in one place in
front of the slow-motion camera oh so
the BAM can sneak up and through the
rock right so so we set it all up and we
got
all the guys we man shoots this BB into
my nipple and it's still in there
like so much alright for the BB Oh weird
weird okay so so now we man shoots the
BB my nipples all apart I'm saying
they're checking it out I'm thinking oh
it's so cool that it stayed in like I
get I get to keep it and and bam sneaks
up throws the water in my face he
[ __ ] punches me and and he actually
did it not in front of the [ __ ]
slow-motion camera which sucks and he
completely broke my nose like that was
my nose was that was the first time I
remember when johnny Knoxville it wasn't
a butter bean beat the [ __ ] out of ya
cocky do that but he cracked his head
open his head harder on the floor Jim
this is the first time I broke my nose
and I was really pissed off at BAM and
because he didn't do it on the
slow-motion camera and because like
there was this continuity thing with all
this blood coming out of my nipple like
the footage didn't get used it and the
footage didn't [ __ ] get used at all
so it happened for [ __ ] nothing and I
was saw and I was so pissed off about it
and I didn't know like I just sort of
stood about in stream I waited two
months it was two months before I
finally snapped and I said [ __ ] I'm
getting my nose fixed and the [ __ ]
movie's gonna pay for it la right and so
so I got so I didn't tell them I tell
them the you know whatever the movie
office is I'm going to this [ __ ]
fancy Beverly Hills nose doctoring you
[ __ ] are paying for it you
[ __ ] [ __ ] and so I go to this
doctor with my crooked nose my broken
[ __ ] crooked nose and the doctor
tells me he says yo I would love to help
you but it's been two months idiot it's
[ __ ] healed that way it's here this
is where the doctor says he said I could
fix it but because it's healed that way
the only way I can fix it is to raise it
to really break free break it the guy
says with a [ __ ] chisel
he says I got a rear break it with a
chisel and I'm like oh I'm good I'm good
and so so I just I lived with my my
crooked ass nose for another like year
maybe a little more than a year and then
comes the Mike Tyson I get where right
and so I showed up at the Charlie Sheen
roasts with a crooked ass nose right and
all I was trying to do loaded they will
you loaded on I was completely sober
and and I showed up with the [ __ ]
rose for the crooked nose all I was
trying to do is get a black eye with
Mike with Mike but when I drove into his
fist and I just like I don't know I got
my nose on it I think Mike Mytilene
dinner he just Mike's a solid guy Mike
solid guy
my nose was so [ __ ] broken that's a
boy it was significantly more broken
when I did it with Mike but but what it
was
were like here I'd crumple them on the
ground Charlie [ __ ] or William Shatner
he's like what the [ __ ] my nerves is
gushing blood I can tell just without
like looking in a mirror I can see just
with what my eyes can see my nose is
nowhere near in the [ __ ] right place
dude it's my nose was it was parked
under my right eye I mean it was
dramatically [ __ ] broken and and that
was the last thing that happened on the
stage so it's like okay now the show's
over and everybody's getting up and
starting to leave but then like I hear
this guy's in steve-o in the crowd like
what everyone's you know milling around
like the show's over but this guy's just
charging towards the stage he's like
steve-o steve-o your nose needs to be
set right now right and I'm because of
my experience with the [ __ ] nose
doctor in Beverly Hills I know that to
be true so I'm like okay wait there's
something to this this guy knows what
he's talking about so I'm like painting
like okay he got goes your nose needs to
be set right now and he comes up to the
stage and I'm like all right talk to me
like like what do I do and he goes don't
worry I'm a kung fu instructor
he says oh yeah I'm a kung fu instructor
I've said like 20 broken noses I know
what I'm doing and decision on the spot
right then I'm like alright well going
to the hospital and getting it taken
care of professionally just sounds like
a [ __ ] pain in the ass this is just
not this is way more convenient I got
nothing to lose it's not like he's gonna
make it look any worse because it was so
bad so I just sat on the edge of the
stage and I trusted this weird kung fu
guy who turned out to be a really nice
guy but like he just puts a thumb on
either side and he's just cook ah just
wrenches it and figs and the tea I'll be
damned if that [ __ ] guy did not fix
my nose completely perfect to where I
showed up at that roast that night with
a crooked nose like I got a Mike Tyson
kungfu nose job with my nose perfectly
[ __ ] straight and I got it done for
free it's the greatest story ever and if
it's Mike if I didn't break my nose on
it was still my face thank God thank God
before and after there was life like
when when it was broken from BAM and
then like how it fixed healed crooked
and then when it was broken from from
Mike and then how it fix out to that
it's the great I'll repost promote this
if anybody wants to see these before and
after photos this for photo sequence
it's unbelievable start of my own safety
what happened we decided the ethical
street oh my god that was like almost
not even my choice I had an intervention
like that was in Johnny Knoxville yeah
put it all together and it wasn't the
kind of like on Iranian on TV when you
watch an intervention they ask are you
willing to accept help
you're not like will you
will you go to treatment right for me
they weren't asking they were telling me
they said were taking me into the
hospital I got the 5150 it was my first
time in the psych ward and not the time
when I was with you there is I had to
psych wards and so uh explain what's 51
crazy [ __ ] means that there's
like if they can prove that you are a
threat to yourself or others which means
if you say anything to the effect I want
to kill myself or if you know or if you
say even just I want to harm myself you
know
or if you're caught cutting or anything
right right maybe you'd be threatened
someone if you're if you pose a threat
to yourself or others then under the law
in California it's called 5150 this
happened to Britney Spears Heather
Locklear just had a couple of them
there's a lot of celebrities on the 5150
Club you're in in Florida I know it's
called the Baker Act but what it means
is that they can just in the involuntary
you know against your will they lock you
up in a psychiatric ward for three days
oh whoa and they can determine if they
want to keep you like in my case when
Knoxville and the Jackass guys brought
me to the hospital like I was I was
spitting on people I was like trying to
[ __ ] throw temper tantrums like that
right when I realized that I wasn't
gonna talk my way out of it and that I
was like getting like that then I'm like
wow I want to smoke a cigarette no I'm
just going raging and I remember I
grabbed a chair I tried to throw it and
at that point like these orderlies
appeared like out of nowhere and they
just grabbed me and slammed me down on
this like stretcher deal and then they
jabbed a needle in my butt cheek and
immediately I took a nap whatever they
had in that needle it was powerful as
[ __ ] because well it went in my butt and
like I've been researching like
tranquilizer darts and
they told me that it would take 20-30
minutes they put something in my ass
that out now and then I woke up in the
part of the hospital where the doors
don't open no matter what you know and
Plus on top of that they had um there
wasn't the this was at cedars-sinai
hospital in LA and they got the like the
east and the west wing like I think if
you're on the East Wing you're the sort
of standard issue like run-of-the-mill
harmful to yourself or others but if
you're on the west wing
you're like in something else category
you know like the the extra like high
security or whatever and so they had me
on the west wing and because of my
behavior they changed me to 50 to 50
which is not just three days it's two
weeks
oh well two week yeah yeah two weeks man
plus that [ __ ] runs expensive too yo we
had well well and being doctors I think
my my treatment my rehab I think came to
about 300 grand and listen to what I'm
thinking today what what was going on
with me back then I was so [ __ ] nuts
yeah I would never dare do that now
before I was just [ __ ] nuts yeah yeah
that's right end up now so I'm in and
thank God they changed me to the two
weeks because if there was no if I was
only in there for three days I would you
know I would've gone straight the drug
dealer like I think it was like gay for
what both you guys like what what drugs
were you using at those times in your
lives cocaine marijuana lot of alcohol
alcohol the story but in 2005 this is
the first time I met Mike where we were
at some kind of nightclub and I was just
so stoked to the [ __ ] Mike Tyson no
way so red and and and everyone was
going from the nightclub to this house
party and so uh you know I found out
where it was and I was like I wasn't
invited but
just like [ __ ] I'm just gonna show up
and I was by myself and and I just like
whatever I took a taxi show up this
random house and I'm not invited and I'm
like I want a party here you know and so
I like ring the doorbell or whatever I
bang on the door and and the door opens
up and it's [ __ ] Mike himself who
opened up the door no I don't know
anybody here you know I don't even know
Mike but uh but um I said I said hey man
is it cool if I come in and Mike like it
was like he's threw a punch it was like
you threw a punch like past me you know
like over my shoulder and lay through it
like next to me past me and hooked it
and then pulled brothers like locked me
in the back of my head not not into the
house
get it here you know there's like this
ghost punch and he hooked it around and
pulled me in the house and we're in the
house like not even a second Eddie says
you got any coke like both pockets right
I'd like for anyone you know an
Eightball is like a fairly substantial
amount of grams in my left pocket I
recall having an iPod that had not even
been touched and in my right pocket I
had like an 8-ball that I'd been like
halfway through at the end of the day it
was it was roughly I think I don't think
I'm exaggerating a lot I think I had
about five grams of cocaine all right
and so I'm like yeah I got a bunch so
Mike and I we go and we go in this
bathroom in the house right we just
[ __ ] lock ourselves in this bathroom
and we were in there for life easy that
was a friend of mine oh yeah it was we
were in there for like [ __ ] three
hours just talking talking I'll never
forget when the gone and here's the
craziest thing is the
like I was a cigarette smoker at the
time I had I smoked Newports Mike Mike
asked me for a cigarette in this
bathroom like right when we first go in
there let me get a cigarette right I
couldn't believe this he takes the
cigarette in his you know Newports
degree he rolls it between his fingers
he gotta explain this to me Mike because
I could I still don't understand it he
rolls it in his fingers back and forth
so that the tobacco falls out on the
bathroom counter right like and he keeps
he keeps doing it rolls backwards so he
gets done with it now like there's the
brown filter on the end and the
cigarette paper is empty it's just like
a cylinder like an empty to a cigarette
paper so then he turns it right-side up
you've got a whole pile of powder
cocaine on the on the bathroom counter
and crush push it all up real fine
powder and Mike's like scooping it in
with like a driver's license credit
cards just scooping it in and pouring
the powder into the tube the cylinder of
cigarette paper right no tobacco mixed
in it's just he's just dumping in just
pure cocaine nothing but cocaine to fill
this cigarette and I'm looking at him
I'm so fascinated I'm looking at I'm
thinking I'm thinking that just can't
work like just logistically like that
can't [ __ ] work that way you know I
like the cocaine the cigarette paper has
to burn away faster than the cocaine
right like you can't just have solid
cocaine with like cigarette paper
wrapped around it and expected to smoke
and I'm watching him do this and I'm
just thinking like this is the most
fascinating like [ __ ] drug addict
science fair experience and sure enough
he got it to work I mean and dude did
you pull the filter out
yeah well the filter out and he's just
like like cradling it and like he smoked
it now I was like a little bit weirded
out by the idea of smoking coke so I was
just snorting it Mike finishes his
his cigarette contraption and then like
he gets done with it and he makes
another I'm so fascinated right I just
keep giving up I started care I just let
Mike have it I'm like dude I was I was
so the experience is so incredible and
been like mind you smoking house cooking
we're locked in like a small bathroom
like it is so dense the smoke in the air
like no crack house could possibly be
that [ __ ] up of like air quality as
far as just being in a cloud of [ __ ]
cooking smoke and we're having this
great conversation and Mike smoking this
this coke smoke after coke smoke and
like for probably like three hours and
then we went through junkies man and
then and then when we were done with
like five [ __ ] grams of cocaine like
three hours later like and then and now
because there's no more cocaine it's
time for Steve where to go he was you
know Stevo
everybody's got you wrong you're Mike
Tyson just told me that I'm smart like
like we're both like a lot [ __ ]
smarter than anybody would ever imagine
I think that's fair to say
you're both dude yeah yeah talk about it
you know saying bro yeah so what you
know I mean [ __ ] man I was in I think
middle school when jackass came on and
the courage of you guys was just -
Matthew those guys I mean
you know like my generations Evel
Knievel's you know just some skater kids
who grabbed the camera and [ __ ]
started doing all kinds of wild
daredevil [ __ ] let's mark that I mean it
my story is pretty simple man like from
birth I was just uh an attention [ __ ]
on steroids I mean is where it wasn't
and I mean you don't have to be Sigmund
Freud to look at like how I grew up and
the you know my alcoholic mom my dad who
is never home who was a corporate
executive like I mean it was insane my
upbringing like I was born in England
and uh when I moved to Brazil my family
major Brazil when I was only six months
old because dad my father
he became the president of Pepsi Cola in
all of Brazil the entire country and
said dad was like a [ __ ] baller ass
[ __ ] and I'm a six-month-old
baby and dad's going off right like
they're living the life in Rio de
Janeiro you know I like and and they got
living maids like my mom or my dad
didn't [ __ ] pay attention to me they
were party and they were on top of the
world and and I spoke my very first
words in Portuguese because I was raised
by the live-in maids he's like I don't
want to see servants but yeah like
live-in maids taught me how to speak my
first words and you know mom was drunk
and dad was never there and so like like
that's probably got something to do with
why I became such an attention [ __ ] and
we kept moving all the time we never
stayed anywhere for more than a couple
years I grew up in five different
countries well and yes so whatever I'm
not gonna tension to ever be I wasn't I
wasn't ever like a bad kid I was like I
was a good kid but I was definitely
gonna become an alcoholic drug addict
there's no way around that
and mmm you know like like I was I was
skateboarding said think about the thing
about alcoholism and and maybe Mike
could relate to this because I think a
lot
a lot of people you know it's a
consensus and among alcoholics is that
there's this feeling of like discomfort
like you're not you're not comfortable
in your own skin you know you don't feel
like I don't know like everybody else
has it figured out but there's just
something you have a low self worth of
yourself yeah right there's something
defective about me there's something I
just do I don't fit in I'm not
comfortable in my own skin I don't know
there's something wrong with me but I'm
uncomfortable and I need something to
help help soothe me you know like when I
was fifteen I was a pretty good kid
I got B's and C's and I was skateboarder
made videos I wasn't that [ __ ] good
at skateboarding but I loved making
videos and and when I graduated high
school which I barely graduated high
school
what were those videos then it was
skateboarding skateboard like half-ass
skateboarding with the blowing off some
stairs right I mean it wasn't bad but it
was it wasn't gonna be like a career and
and there was a little bit of funny
stuff mixed in but so I graduated from
high school barely and then I went to
the University of Miami now I'm at the
University of Miami less than two weeks
hurricanes uh-huh hurricanes in less
than two weeks after classes started my
freshman year I was already on final
disciplinary probation yeah uh-huh
in the dorms and then I got kicked out
of the dorms and I failed out of the
front of my classes and I just dropped
out I just gave up so now I'm on my way
you know I'm on my way out of the
University of Miami and this is 1993 you
know I was a long [ __ ] time ago and
people are like what are you gonna do
now I'm like I just turned 19 years old
and they're like what are you gonna do
now you [ __ ] up and I'm like oh I'll
be cool I'm gonna I'm gonna become a
famous stunt man I'm a videotape [ __ ]
crazy here with my I'm gonna videotape
crazy [ __ ] with my video camera and I'm
gonna become a famous stunt man and
everyone's gonna think I'm rad and like
everybody I told this to they just
thought what a shame
what a [ __ ] tragedy this guy of what
a [ __ ] loser
that everyone just felt bad for me and I
don't know that I believe that would be
successful with that but but I had no
other option because I had proven time
and time again I've proven that anytime
I tried to get a job I got fired I got
fired from every [ __ ] job I ever had
and I I couldn't bring couldn't go to
class I couldn't read a book I couldn't
do [ __ ] that I don't want to do the only
thing I wanted to do is make dumb videos
and I knew I wasn't that good at
skateboarding something like I just
can't be crazy there's gonna do the
crazy [ __ ] and I and I can't thought
that I would just fail I didn't think I
was gonna succeed you know I felt like
okay I'm gonna I don't have the survival
skills man I can't keep a job I can't
earn my way I'm gonna die a failure but
I'm thinking to myself before I die
a failure I want to get a ton of video
footage cuz I'm like oh I'll be gone but
that video will still play so I'll still
be alive if you came my religion man
like girl like I'm going to live like
we're all gonna die but I want to live
forever you know this is I want to live
forever I never gave a [ __ ] about money
I wanted like like attention and I
wanted attention for eternity a big word
yeah I didn't think I would be
discovered or successful I thought I
thought I'm gonna be dead and I'll be
like the van Gogh of dipsh it's like
maybe I'll get discovered after I let me
feel now well now different now like now
like you know we do we get older people
don't give us much of a [ __ ] about us
anymore
I think they'll always care about you
but uh but you know like it's it's
getting older scary you're gonna change
your priorities you know and not my
priorities like what I want to do is buy
land and open up an animal sanctuary no
I want to have that be my legacy
well it's [ __ ] awesome dude I mean
it's great to have you here my way what
a treat man well by the way I mean you
you made this you had this idea I'm
gonna be the [ __ ] world's most famous
[ __ ] man but that was unprecedented
at the time there wasn't any YouTube or
Internet videos [ __ ] going on the way
that I came up was by spending money
that I didn't even have to spend on VHS
tapes and recording back and forth
between two VCRs
to make my edits and then taking the
physical VHS tape this cassette
videotape and then going to the the post
office with money I couldn't afford to
spend to ship these [ __ ] tapes to
anybody I thought would watch them who
might be able to help me and it was all
people in the skateboard industry and I
did I didn't get anywhere for I didn't
get anywhere for like I don't know I was
homeless for three years Wow I was
homeless for three years and when I say
homeless that was more of a couch surfer
a homeless person and a couch that's a
homeless about my couch surfer when
you've got people skills and and
personality if you're a likeable guy you
know people let you sleep on their sofa
until you pee on it which I always would
because that's the thing if you drink
enough you gotta [ __ ] pee in your
sleep learned that time and time again
when I was drinking the hazard of it
yeah I know nobody likes that either so
I three years in and I found out about
Ringling Brothers and Barnum & Bailey
Clown College ooh yeah I was living with
my sister at the time she found out
about it yeah Florida isn't stereo sort
of Florida yeah and this was in 1997
my sister had me living in her house and
I'm just a [ __ ] [ __ ] and I'm
eating all our food and I'm everything's
a mess and she's like what am I so she
was working at a newspaper and and and
when she was taking a [ __ ] at work and
and on the toilet was this book of
trivia like trivia questions so she's
taking a [ __ ] in and she gets this
question that she reads it it says
what's the only college that has no
tuition you can just go for free and it
said Ringling Brothers and Barnum &
Bailey Clown College if you can get in
then it's free because they want
equal opportunity for people to run away
with the circus you know and and it was
a big tax write-off for the for the
circus and it was prestigious it was
statistically harder to get into Clown
College than Harvard well you had you
had to audition to even get an
application and get an audition for the
chance to apply and stop my sister I'm
gonna get into this thing and I was
laying in my own vomit at my buddy's
house I've I come in I'm so hungover I'm
hurting so bad and I see this you know
this this thing with this audition
schedule and and a headline like 97 and
I loved where we lived in Albuquerque
New Mexico and and I look down in 97 and
Albuquerque was on there but but Bulow's
for 98 I said I don't worry about that
you know because everywhere the circus
went mm-hmm and and so I saw 90 and I'm
like ah that's not till next year so I'm
like I'm like you know like [ __ ] my
sister and it comes out to me she says
how are you getting to Denver by Monday
I think she wanted me out like like
Clown College seemed like a great
opportunity for me because I wanted to
be this famous stunt what did you learn
there yeah the only thing you had to
learn was still walking like still
walking alone that there was a very so
many different
we trained 14 hours a day and then you
had to learn how to do your makeup well
do you know I mean she was training and
I didn't give that much of a [ __ ] about
being a clown
I just wanted to become this crazy
famous stuntman and I thought if I could
graduate from this prestigious you know
Ringling Brothers clown College with
it's so hard to get into then like when
I'm trying to become a famous stunt man
I'll have like some legitimacy where the
be like it's like yo I'm a trained
circus professional you know like I'm
the [ __ ] you've heard of the circus
and I'm like like legit and so I went
there to try to further my goal of
becoming a stuntman and and
at work at the same time people I was
been sending my stunt videos to there
was a skateboard magazine and the guy
running the magazine became the creator
and the director of Jackass
oh and so it just kind of fell in my lap
like they started putting me in their
magazine and in their videos and then
their videos turned into jackass when do
they start paying you oh my god that's
the best question I came the first
season of Jackass I found it in five
days in the summer of year 2000 and I'd
been working in a circus and when I got
fired in the five days like the first
thing I did I was picked up the goldfish
I took the elephant food that I died
took like like 50 gallon 50 gallon 50
gallon tubs of elephant poo from the
elephants in the circus and I just three
of them thought I felt a kiddie pool did
the back flip up the ladder and the
elephant poo diving the pick up the
goldfish
we stapled the Jackass letters across my
butt cheeks I did the shark hugs I got
bitten by a shark I had that bum fishing
I didn't film the whole first season in
a slit a week and five days I filmed
everything all my parts for the whole
first season in five days and and my pay
rate Mike my pay rate was theirs it
wasn't per episode it was per bit and if
the bit was legitimately like dangerous
like life and limb you know you could
get really [ __ ] up then I got 500 and
if the bit was like if the bit was like
a little sort of gag like kind of street
prank and it was easy and it wasn't
dangerous 200 all right so a so not at
the end of the five days I'm sitting
there
don't tell me it's all about the Jersey
Shore people are like a million in
episodes but so the the end of the five
days I'm sitting I got my finger all
bandaged up cuz check it out I got cool
and scars from the shark bite hell yeah
dude yeah and some I'll beat up and
hungover and like I wasn't even that
worried about how much money like I was
earned what I wanted to do I was writing
down for the further for the director
for everybody on the production yeah
this is what I expect to see on TV you
know like don't don't forget to include
this in the show you know I wrote down
like a list of everything and I first I
brought down goldfish right and I'm
thinking go ahead and write the price of
what they owe me next to each better
something in a goldfish right now if you
you could when you could choke on the
goldfish right it could [ __ ] turn
around and as it comes up like it to go
on the scales the wrong way it could
trash your [ __ ] you know there's a
lot that could go wrong
swallow your goldfish right but I'm
thinking to myself I want these people
to know how [ __ ] badass I am I want
them to know how gnarly I am I'm [ __ ]
but I brought down goldfish and then
next to it I wrote 200 I had too much
pride to say I considered that dangerous
200 and at the end of the day after
taxes I want to say I made less than
1500 bucks for the first year oh man and
then and then and then when that when
the [ __ ] and when they when the shake
came out the first season came out by
the time the third episode aired which
is exactly two weeks into the run it was
officially the highest rated show in the
history of MTV I mean it's not it wasn't
higher ratings than the VM
or anything but for like a half-hour
standard format of programming the
profit margin and the ratings or
unprecedented it was it was by far the
most profitable highest-rated [ __ ]
communist Eve when did you become happy
from them paying you what did that day
ever happen I was happier without money
I feel like for some reason no [ __ ]
way to be paid for your service I
understand that man like I understand
that and yeah
you know there are a lot of us too you
know there are a lot of us who split it
up I'll tell you what the next step was
so it's the highest rated show in the
history of MTV and I get the call to let
me know that and my contract wasn't had
no options or anything it was like start
from scratch you know new contract so
the producer calls me up and he says hey
we're a hit
he says Senesh so MTV wants the first
season was eight episodes he says MTV
wants 16 more episodes so there's so
they're ordering seasons two and three
in one go 16 more episodes and he says
and we know we're gonna have to pay you
so we're gonna give you two grand per
episode and in my head on the phone the
phone calls were thinking and yeah I'm
thinking to myself 16 episodes times 2
that's $32,000 I'm [ __ ] rich like
here's to be completely honest I think
that my attitude about money and and how
I started out in my career with business
stuff like it's it's it's [ __ ] up but
but the truth is looking at my parents
growing up like my dad was a baller my
dad went on to become the president of
Nabisco well like he was the president
he was like a hotshot CEO and from like
when I was in high school my dad was
chauffeur driven to work and if and if I
overslept at all if I'm running late in
the morning and I didn't have time to
ride my skateboard to school or ride my
bike to school
I would have to ride with dad and catch
a ride with his chauffeur and that
[ __ ] embarrassed me as a kid growing
up as a kid growing up like my mom's
drinking got so out of hand that my
sisters couldn't take it she went to
boarding school and like and dad became
more and more successful and more and
more like rich and so so the dynamic for
me as a kid growing up was that my
family got smaller and the house got
bigger and I was like I was embarrassed
of how [ __ ] obnoxiously big our house
was and I was I remember going to my dad
when Dad was like running Delmonte the
the canned fruit company like he'd took
the family to ta'kenya were there than
the main pineapple factory because he's
got to like you know show up and like
you know maybe you know just do would've
show up and do whatever yes he planned
it on the like this week in February
when we had spring break you know again
I was in England and so like we'd spring
break and this is when I was like like
11 or 12 fifth or sixth grade so I went
back and forth to England any case we go
to Kenny on our spring break he brings
the whole family and remember when we
into Nairobi this is how I remember it
dad says it's different but I know this
[ __ ] [ __ ] like today the only thing
we disagree on is the car we come into
that out of the airport in Nairobi which
is in Kenya just poverty man like people
with like no shoes and like your
tattered clothes and there's flies all
over and they're like begging you and
they assure us like the family end of
this like limousine you know and like
like open up the you know the guests
just get us into this car and the car
sitting there and I'm inside the car and
these poor people are like scratching at
the windows you know they're like
they're like begging please help us
please never seen that before
yeah and
I'm sitting there in this car looking at
this poverty I'd never seen poverty like
that but I remember thinking to myself
what the [ __ ] have I ever done to
deserve to be in the car instead of
scratching at the car like wow I'm a
[ __ ]
I knew damn well I have [ __ ] up
everything I never had a good report
card you don't like in high school I did
a little better with you know for a
while but I just was a problem man it
was like always a [ __ ] problems I was
always in trouble I was a [ __ ] and and
I just felt I felt ashamed man I felt
ashamed of like what did I do to be in
this car you know and I felt ashamed of
the house that was so big and I didn't
want kids from school to see me get out
of a [ __ ] chauffeur-driven car like I
would ride I would ride like shotgun
with my dad's reading the newspaper in
the backseat shotgun and hug the driver
you know I like to pretend that the
driver was my dad no a lot of this a lot
of this attitude about about that like
like it I just saw that my parents and I
feel bad saying it but I'm just saying
it because it's the truth
both of my parents I feel like I just
saw them like blatantly think that they
were better because they had money you
know like I saw them like just think
they were they were better you know I
saw that whenever they had friends over
to the house that it was just like a big
pissing match of like oh my kids going
to this school and it's better than you
know it's just like this is this
competition and I didn't like it I felt
that my parents were like corroded by
wealth I felt like you know it was like
honestly the feeling in my in my growing
up was like Daddy rate raised religious
it was like the honest answer is now I
wasn't raised religious like my parents
felt that they had enough money why
would they need religion
so so I took that kind of mindset to in
my life yeah and I could have done been
a more aggressive businessman but I
never gave a [ __ ] about money Europe and
never also when we were in Kenya we
would simply show up at this pineapple
factory this is the craziest part show
up this cop i nap on factory and like
it's so hot and [ __ ] sweaty and and
like all the workers have like flies all
over them
and I'm like I turn to my dad I said I
said dad how can you let like you're the
boss dad here's a [ __ ] boss how can
you let people work in in these
conditions like this this is [ __ ] up
you know however it and dad dad says he
goes he says well the list of people who
have jobs in this pineapple factory is
nowhere near as long as the list of
people who are waiting for jobs in this
pineapple factory so if anybody doesn't
like it here they can get the hell out
and be replaced by someone who will work
harder and I remember thinking [ __ ] my
dad's a dick right and then fast forward
to when we were filming the Jackass TV
show when we were in the middle of that
run of the seasons two and three where
I'm getting the two grand per episode
and and our cameraman he was always on
the show - Rick Rick goes up to the
director one day and he says he says yo
I just I just spent like like however
many hours it was like twelve twelve
hours in one day like busting my ass
filming a [ __ ] like a national like
worldwide like hit TV show and I made
less money then if I shot a [ __ ] half
a page photo let's add four for this
[ __ ] skate magazine we used to make
like how does that make sense like I
shoot a [ __ ] photo for a piece of
[ __ ] skateboard magazine
make more than I do making this [ __ ]
hit TV show how does that make for their
balls off how does that make sense so
Jeff looks at Ricky goes then go shoot a
skate ad like you'll be replaced by
someone who [ __ ] work harder and
thinking myself damn so it's not that my
dad was a dick it's this that's how the
[ __ ] world works
yeah [ __ ] so it's like the only way to
like get to get up the only way to come
up is to make it so that you can't be
replaced by someone who work hard you
need to make yourself work for yourself
you need to be irreplaceable yeah you
need to make it you need to like you
need to have like to have to control you
no one can take your place yeah no doubt
man and and no one can take my [ __ ]
place and no I can take Mike's place
yeah but like so what I'm gonna do now
you know like it's getting to a point
where it's like I doing okay it's like
Joyce yeah don't do it don't do it like
how much how much longer do I do this
[ __ ] you know and it's like I gotta
think like what like okay I either stop
or I gotta go big like one last [ __ ]
go for it I got got one and and I had
this idea a list of ideas that aren't
like particularly new ideas I had that
happen forever but they were so far
there was there's just that list of
ideas that was just too [ __ ] up to go
for it ya know and so I call it my
bucket list
right I call it my bucket list and and
like yeah there's nothing on my bucket
list that didn't happen for so long for
like no reason there's like a solid
[ __ ] reason why this [ __ ] should
never happen and now I'm just going for
it because I feel like I've got a
limited amount of time I'll give you an
example of like something on my list to
show you how ridiculous it is like
anytime anybody ever asked me if I've
been skydiving before I always said [ __ ]
that - everybody does that what am I
gonna do something everybody does I do
[ __ ] nobody does so I said years ago
probably fifteen years ago
I said if I ever go skydiving my first
time you know you gotta have a dude
strapped on your back like a tandem
skydive instructor well I'm gonna be
[ __ ] butt ass naked and I'm gonna be
and I'm gonna be [ __ ] furiously
jacking off and I will not Lord for a
long time like four days and then when
I'm whacking it when I'm whacking in I
reached the point of no return right
around the first squirt that's when I
leave the plane so I'm free-falling
through the [ __ ] sky cranking out the
biggest load you ever saw and I called
the idea of skyjacking right and that's
like everything on my list is taken to
the next level and like I shouldn't say
this but I'm legitimately concerned that
I'm not leaving myself anywhere to go
with that [ __ ] so I'm so like I'm
savoring every minute of every day and
every minute of every show Wow well I'm
I haven't even peaked yet but and this
bucket list show dude there's like all
over the venues you got to be like 21 to
enter and there's like legal waivers
like by entering this room you
acknowledge that like that you
essentially can't sue over like I got
[ __ ] I have people like in in almost
every city I've gone to on this tour
there's been like at least one dude
passed the [ __ ] out straight-up fainted
in the crowd just from the footage
because my act like my new the bucket
list tour it's a stand-up comedy act
right and go through those I go through
the whole list right and tell the story
about every out [ __ ] outrage and then
after each bit I screen the [ __ ] chin
so you see it you see it on the screen
and the theater and you can't see it I
mean where but on this tour and so I get
making the whole bucket list a series
right now right now to to her and then
later when I'm done with the tour I'll
put the series out holy so how much they
gonna pay you for that uh your brother
no money man yeah I know man the money's
on the table I haven't done the deal yet
well thank you so much very much you
guys I was so thrilled man and I like to
consider myself a pretty dope podcast
guest man I'll tell you that our jackass
family has always been like like almost
like worship Mike Tyson you know it was
always like such a goal to uh to film
with Mike like on the first movie the
very first movie they had the thing
where they put the Valentine like it was
like a Valentine I'm in the wall and it
was like you know it was supposed to be
from like groupies like yeah the words
got smaller and smaller so your face had
to get circles than the fist Cantor
that idea was written for Mike he's
supposed to be were hoping Mike would be
it was supposed to be Mike on the other
side of the wall oh no I don't know you
know what it was is that that Mike Mike
wasn't in maybe a good place at that
time
yeah man has 4d right like I know we
should wrap it up but buddy here's that
for me like we used to play the black
eye game and and and when when when Mike
showed up and we were in the psych ward
together this was my second side chord
and and and and I'm stint on Mike I'm
like hey Mike dude I got this idea on a
film with you I just need you to hold
your fists out and let me run into it
with my face yeah and and it was just a
straight-up bad time to try to pitch my
god Mike wasn't in the psych ward
because he's having guns dude
he wasn't doing like and what a sweet
guy mike says mike says i don't want to
hurt you steve and but then when the
Charlie Sheen Rose we did make it happen
let me just say I can speak for everyone
in our jackass family Knoxville Tremayne
like everybody that we have always been
like such fans like did the I showed you
my I've in my house posters it's just a
real honor man it's so good to see you
and to see you doing good and looking
healthy it's awesome dad to get together
Thank You Man guys you're in dark places
yeah you know what hats are awesome what
happened people come from nation that
we're here now we're talking rational
it's beautiful I think we're actually
pretty rational on coke but maybe less
myself and it's so great there that we
can get together and it doesn't even
have to be like because I have coke yeah
my [ __ ] crazy unique fucked-up comedy
tour man like you can find the dates on
steve-o calm also my instrument like all
my social media handles are just at
steve-o without the - I'm easy to find
and whenever this gets posted I'll make
sure I post that that before and after
with bamberg in my nose and that heals
[ __ ] up and then mike bridge my nose
and then it's perfect i'm social media
and let's do it again awesome man thank
you guys thanks Mike it's a great show
everybody till next time we're out of
here
[Music]